making it big making it big alvin's
gonna make it big big big
[Music]
[Applause]
hello welcome back to tasty's making it
big the show where i make large versions
of some of america's most beloved foods
today we are going to be making giant
chicken parm my good friend andrew rae
from babbage culinary universe actually
sent in this video with a challenge
check it out hey alvin andrew ray here
from binging with babish and i want to
tell you a little bit about chicken
parmesan it was invented in 1900 and
popularized by them and i love it it's
my go-to hangover dish it's my death row
meal it is my meal probably tonight from
talking about it so much what makes a
chicken parm good well
i've learned over the years that you
need crisp you need cheesy you need
saucy you need chickeny and you need a
little bit of sog
i don't understand chicken parmesan i
just appreciate it i would appreciate it
if you were to create a larger version
of a normal chicken parmesan normally
still pretty big portions but if you
were to make it's
big make it big
[Music]
all right thank you andrew for those
kind words and the invigorating
challenge we're going to start hammering
some chicken so we have a lot of chicken
breasts here plastic wrap chicken breast
weapon of obliteration here we go
this is a
oddly therapeutic and because
this is going to be a large chicken parm
i don't want to pound it up too thin or
else the structural integrity of it may
do that so we're going to start with
that for now one this is great you just
failed the test we had like a bad
breakup bad customer service call
maybe your internet is down and you have
nothing to do at home
just make some chicken parm and
everything will be okay
with the help of the wonderful culinary
team we have 10 pounded chicken breasts
thank you for them for saving my arms
and my hands and now we play a little
bit of chicken tetris so the goal of
this game because i like games is to get
one large chicken with 10 pieces and
we're just gonna build and see what we
get more edges equals more fun trying to
overlap the thinner sides with the
thicker ones so that way everything just
kind of stays together can't do this in
tetris but you got to move the blocks
around to cheat it these two are going
to be my glue spike side is going to
help hopefully the chicken stick to each
other
trying to use these almost as
indentations for nails well during this
aggressive meat physical session we're
gonna create a little some holes which
we do need to patch up so we're gonna
use these as our back up probably one
over here and away we go
all right this is the end of the massage
you gotta smooth things out gave it the
beating now we gotta make sure
everybody's feeling all right
okay it's quite large or that's pretty
cool all right time to get this onto a
circular tray and into the freezer so we
can fry this whole thing we have one
large chicken pizza ready for the
freezer
so chicken parmesan one of the great
things about it is that you get to enjoy
crispy chicken with cheese and sauce so
we're gonna make our version of a tomato
sauce garlic
onion or chili flakes
ooh it smells real nice this is gonna
take a little bit to cook so we'll be
right back
okay so now onions garlic pepper nice
and sweaty and get tomato paste in it
smush that down oh that smells strong
that is a lot of tomato paste so tomato
paste cooking off some of that rawness
we're going to continue with the tomato
sauce this is about 50 tomatoes in this
pot right now
good job alvin first spelled the day
that's fine i'm used to it by now
now we stir this should cook for quite a
while it's nice simmer all the flavors
going oregano i'm going to do half now
i love the smell of basil it's not so
good all right so this is going to hang
out for quite some time let all the
flavors get to know each other and then
we are going to cook some very
large pasta see you guys in the back
so we are in the back tasty kitchen
where we have a huge
huge pot of boiling water elegantly
prepared for us by the culinary team and
we have
approximately 2
000 grams of pasta oh look and there's
hip now with the wooden paddle amazing
thank you sir what a lifesaver
this will be our stirring utensil for
the day oh we gotta salt the water in
goes
the pasta
all right we're trying to get it to
maybe a couple minutes under done it'll
be finished in some sauce then
it'll be ready what's that one song they
sing in the harry potter potions isn't
there like a chant oh trouble
[Music]
something wicked this way comes whoo
these noodles are looking really great
so we're gonna try one
oh that's good oh it's dumb
[Music]
and there you go god that's so
satisfying
it's like fishing for gold
[Music]
i wish there's some of the pasta water
for the cooking
it should be good all right we're gonna
finish off the pasta now
a little spill
i spilled
oh that's cool
largest scale pasta finishing i've ever
seen let's start with that see where
that gets us add a little bit of this
pasta water and you go
just like andrew does in the video some
nice freshly grated parm
little touch of water this tastes pretty
good but this will also make it taste a
lot better two sticks of butter gives
the pasta a nice sheen nice flavor i
think it's what restaurants do
to make their pasta taste really good
and if they do it
andrew does it
i'm gonna do it too
[Music]
very interesting sound we have
the most important part is to eat
to taste
[Music]
this is done
i i'm gonna go finish up the rest of the
stuff now and try not to eat this whole
entire thing because it's pretty good
so we need to set up our breading
station usually you have a three-part
breading station flour egg breadcrumb we
still have a three-part breading station
it is just now very large so flour
[Music]
don't do that eggs i'm lazy so i'm going
to use technology to make my life easier
[Music]
this is a massive breading station
and for the breadcrumb mix seasoned
regular breadcrumbs huncle because
panko's great garlic and onion powder
basil and oregano because i'm gonna make
a mess we're gonna need more of this and
a good amount of parm inside the bread
crumb itself this is a very well
seasoned mixture you put all good stuff
in there you know it's gonna turn out
good
i'm gonna get gloves
all right
we have our chicken pizza
so
this has been freezing for stability and
rigidity
flour oh this does not fit it's all good
i might just chop off this part here in
making a bake we provide solutions
and large food ta-da
all better all right got some flour
all right
[Music]
this is awesome also got to dust off the
excess of course
into the egg
satisfying let's see if we can do it
this way
that way i don't have to flip it all
right let's make a little bed
straight in you go
it's a pre-made mix from the culinary
team help me again with the assist
appreciate it double coat
come on
it's like playing those marble games
it's one breaded chicken time to get
this guy back in the freezer before we
fry just some extra on the bottom in
case it gets a little wet to the freezer
we are about to fry this chicken we have
a large pot of oil which is
around 350 or so this is very dangerous
but this is also the only way that we
can
fry this this beautiful thing don't do
this at home kids just watch the video
and in
we
go
[Music]
slowly
look at that
[Music]
oh you hear that it sounds like good
stuff all right we got a good crust
going on here
everything's looking pretty pretty good
so we are going to
take it out
if i can
like this
yeah there we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's nice some of this
just chicken or cheese residue out of
here we don't want none of that and
edges are nice and crispy middle could
use some work so this is going to go
into the oven just a little bit until
it's
ready
we have
a large chicken patty that has been
fried so this is the base for chicken
parmesan and
as per andrew's video i really like this
idea he took he puts basil on top of the
chicken and that way i think it's really
nice because it gives it a nice perfume
this is that real farm to table it's not
farm to table this is farm on my table i
really like where this is going
and next probably one of the reasons why
everybody likes eating chicken parmesan
is the cheese so this is
fresh mozzarella boom
bam
bop
bad
it's like a pizza a little more cheese
never hurting anybody that's actually a
lie if you're lactose intolerant you
probably have felt pain from all of this
and
the namesake for the dish parmesan all
those times when you're at the
restaurants and the waiter says hey
would you like some parmesan and you say
yes they always never give you enough
but today this is my show this is my
dish i put as much parmesan on this
thing as i want and i'm not gonna say
when don't tap out we're gonna do that
here
arm is tapping out though
switch
one
very stacked piece of chicken now needs
to go into the broiler pour into a hot
oven for one
final transformation
all right i'm coming off screen with
this coming out of the oven oh heck yeah
chicken parm looking really good cheese
is all bubbly skin is crispy you can
still see the basil i think
this will be a great plate for the
chicken parm
okay pasta goes on first
oh my god you served that at a
restaurant it's like 200. yeah carbon
where you at don't don't actually i
don't nobody tagged them i've i want i
want to go to that restaurant so i
haven't had it before so i don't want
them to get mad at me that's like what
normal serving size for americans this
has been the most useful tool we've had
on this show and it was designed as just
like a cookie tray but now it has become
a scooper a chopper a bench scraper you
know jack of all trades we have
great cheese so might as well just use
this cheese on it this is what people
feel like when they go to the strip club
they just throw money i haven't been to
one but i would like to try just for the
experience of it i'm gonna making it
rain on on the pasta
hi mom
all right a little bit of basil cheese
is the only thing i would probably let
rain or make rain
all right
half done heck yeah right on top you go
big dude
[Music]
final touch the sauce i think it's a
smart move to put the sauce on top not
underneath that it's not as soggy that's
chicken parm make it rain some final
touches there you have it
this
this is very heavy this is a quite large
chicken parm i think it's time to eat
oh let me send a video to andrew though
i want him to see alvin let's take a
look at what she did
[Laughter]
i think it's big i think you made it big
alvin you did me proud you did me so
proud it looks unbelievable
it's huge i love how you said that both
the sauce on top and the basil
underneath the cheese were my tips both
of those are from other places carmelo
soprano or america's test kitchen two
things that have never been said in the
same sentence before but the pasta looks
amazing the chicken parmesan looks huge
so mission accomplished the name of the
show is making it large
uh making it making a giant making
making it big
man i really wish i could have been
there to eat that it looks incredible
you did great and now all you have to do
is just make it for me again uh when you
come over next okay because i'll be
hungry i'll savor him
bye alvin
time to eat just uh give myself a little
serving of pasta here i can make a
normal portion it's just like a slice of
pizza oh heck yeah yeah look at that
let's go in cheers
for some reason i don't doubt that this
one is going to taste good but we'll see
hmm
[Music]
i was right this does taste good chicken
is nice pasta's nice everything is nice
you know just a normal meal in america
looks so good
i'm gonna finish chewing
well there we go i am going to eat that
quite a long time because it is quite
delicious i also have a lot of crew a
lot of friends that i could feed that
with so i'm not concerned about taking
care of that chicken farm and maybe i'll
give some to andrew who knows but that
was it this is the end of the season
thank you guys for watching again to
watch me go through a bunch of hoops and
hurdles to try and make a lot of giant
versions of some of the food that we all
like to eat you know it's been a wild
ride huge shout out to the crew the
culinary team the art team for making
things like the giant kitkat rapper you
know the editing team that is editing
this episode that you are watching right
now but that's it for me thank you guys
for watching and i'll see you later
peace
[Applause]
you